[Music]
[Music]
what's your damage River babes just
kidding you guys know that I could never
be rude to you guys hey everyone I'm
your host Liana Galera and this is your
Sweetwater secrets preview show for
episode 316 chapter 51 big fun
aka season three's musical episode now
obviously today I'm channeling our HBIC
Cheryl blossom as she steps into the
role of Heather Chandler and the best
part is I totally already owned this red
scrunchie so this is already a great day
I look a little insane I'm excited now
today is going to be packed with
exclusive brand new interviews with the
Riverdale cast from the set of Heather's
the musical plus as always I'll be
teasing you with my three clues and
answering a live round of your comments
and theories how very but first let's
take a look at your hisses and kisses
from our Sweetwater after show for
episode 315 chapter 50 American Dreams
kicking us off with something we can all
agree on Maya
Oh Mary posted kisses - Nana rose for
just being her wonderful little self yep
Nana rose for mayor next up Karina M
wrote hisses - the fact that we just saw
a heartbreaking phallus breakup when
they're not even together and hisses -
Gladys because she's ruining everything
oh I know the scene between F P and
Alice was just absolutely heartbreaking
and while we're talking about F P Donna
the dead had some thoughts saying hisses
- Jughead for thinking his father will
break so easily dude your dad was a gang
leader he knows your mama's dirty
give him more credit I think Jughead
mainly just didn't want to wreck the
birthday bash yeah meanwhile Karis Chi
added kisses to Betty for telling
Jughead about Gladys and kisses - jug
for believing her you know a season ago
he wouldn't have believed her and the
fact that he did shows just how strong
they've grown true and while bug head
continues to be solid
there were quite
new relationships that crumbled last
week when we take a look at veggie Carly
Rock said both Veronica and Reggie are
at fault Baraka should have treated
Reggie better as an employee
Reggie shouldn't have asked Veronica
about being a partner when she's already
in a tight spot fair point but when it
came to show knee it seems like the
Phantom was divided over which lady
caused the sinking of this ship now
polina de la rocha Armand commented
pisses to Tony for not caring about
Cheryl's trip and not inviting her to
the pretty poisons trip and hisses - the
inks but kisses to the Shoni rendevouz
meanwhile mat light seems to be on Team
Tony because he posted hisses - Cheryl
furred jumping on everything Tony was
trying to say Cheryl your girlfriend was
trying to have an open and healthy
dialogue with you offer compromise Matt
also said kisses to LeAnn and to the
editors for putting Cheryl's what was
that exactly right after you described
that Tony should be allowed to have
other friends and a life outside the
relationship I audibly left yay you know
my editor Hank and I always love to put
lines from the episode and fun different
places in the Sweetwater after-show so
I'm glad that our little inside jokes
are making you all smile but before we
move on there were so many comments
during the last week's live preview Q&A
and they were all asking the same thing
who is peaches and cream now you asked
and now I'm answering I'm pleased to
introduce you to our very first
interview with Bernadette Beck the
actress who plays peaches and cream take
a look she's in crane well she's new to
Riverdale
she's a very glamorous but kind of like
a tough bruiser
gangster kind of girl she's part of a
new gang called the pretty poison so
it's like an all-girl gang at the moment
and sort of backstory about peaches and
cream that a few people don't really
know about is that her mother used to
own a pawn shop and it used to be
burgled by the Southside serpent so
there's sort of this like enemy
vengeance that she's got towards the
serpents and yeah peaches and cream is
sort of this kind of the muscle of
Riverdale of the group and she gets
things done she's very independent and
I'm actually very excited to sort of
learn more about the character as
character grows and there you have it
that's peaches and cream and I think
burden that seems like an absolute
sweetheart so I'm excited to get to know
her character more and you'll be seeing
a lot more of her in this week's episode
and that leads us straight into our
promo for episode 316 chapter 51 big fun
roll it
heather's deals with teen alienation and
desperation what's your damage child of
the corn let's start figuring out what
we are your mother and I are separated
Riverdale's filled with a lot of
desperate folks heather's is being used
to eat doctorate students into a cult
are you intrigued ready for more good
well then let's jump right into my three
clues number one I've said before that
how hath no fury like a blossom scorned
but a breakup blossom is even scarier
number two the songs aren't the only
things on fire in this episode and
number three a character from the past
makes a haunting return mm-hmm now et's
cameras caught up with the Riverdale
cast while they were filming this
musical extravaganza and they had a lot
to say about what it was like for them
to take on these role of Heather's and
if they'd even seen Heather's the
musical take a look I obviously knew
what Heather's was but I actually had
never seen the movie which some people
found surprising I was disappointed
I mean Heather's is top five favorite
films of all time and some people were
like oh you know it was just like not
really my thing
it was a creepy movie it's not a movie
that I would put on and be like oh yeah
let's watch the Heather it's a little
violent for me how could it not be your
thing that's literally should be
everyone's thing there's a lot of movies
out there you're not gonna see him all
but so I you know obviously I watched it
it's very surprised by the dark content
cuz I actually didn't necessarily know
what it was about it was very impressed
by the fashion I know that Heather's is
a very dark film especially the ending
and I think Riverdale is kind of
bringing light to it which is a strange
thing to say because I find Riverdale
typically makes thing
darker but I think Heather's musical
it's a great break up in The Gargoyle
King sequence that we've got going on
right now and I think how there's a
musical is almost like a light-hearted
thing for us to be doing and the chain
of events that's happening in Riverdale
right now I really think Heather's is
the perfect match for our show there are
just a lot of similar themes and I think
every time they pick a musical it makes
a lot of sense with our show it's very
much a love letter to the musical while
still having our our cast of players
sort of jump into their skins it meshes
very well with what's happening in
Riverdale right now to kind of bring the
two together and make this episode now
turn to my favorite part of these live
previews your live comments and theories
and questions and everything so here we
go so you guys have already been
flooding the comment section right now
let's see ah the Fallas stands going cry
I am right there with you that was the
most heartbreaking scene seeing Machin
really whip out those tears was just
gut-wrenching and honestly I just need
them back together
I thought the FP was gonna be the one
who would be able to pull Alice out of
the farm craziness but I don't know
what's gonna happen now creepypasta
Welcome Back said I'm not excited for
the musical I'm just excited for
bug-head
you can be excited for both close says
okay I have a theory that fangs and
Kevin are gonna date and Kevin is gonna
quit the farm part of that theory might
come true I'm not gonna say which part
CJ says LeAnn sweetwater secrets is
awesome but do you have any idea why
what Heather's is and why Heather's is
called Heather's I only ask because I've
never heard of it before
CJ okay first of all I understand that
we have a lot of young Ripper babes out
there but Heather's is an iconic movie
from the 80s starring the lovely Winona
Ryder and Christian Slater it's
extremely dark it's extremely violent
and it's just one of the most quotable
movies ever but a lot of the quotes are
let's just say not appropriate with the
CW you'll see them kind of alter them
tonight but basically long story short
for those of you who are not familiar
heather's is about a group of friends
three of them they're all named Heather
and their
kind of mini terrorists who rule the
school and there's a girl named Veronica
who wants to join the Heather's and just
ish goes down it's amazing if you're
over the age of like 13 check it out
okay Sydney oh my gosh I just want
Jughead to play JD and Heather's and
Betty to play Veronica and then the
poisons could be the Heather's I'm
actually really pleased with how they
cast it I love that Betty Veronica and
Cheryl are the Heather's and then miss
Josie's playing Veronica and actually
Sweet Pea is playing JD which creates
some really interesting drama
considering Sweet Pea and Josie is to
kind of date Mikaela says I'm sorry that
Cheryl space and the thumbnail picture
here is about as dead of a stare as you
can get and it's fantastic oh man Emmy
for Madeline Peck tonight because every
scene that she's in she absolutely
crushes and seeing her play Heather
Chandler is just amazing there is one
scene tonight and I'm gonna break it all
down in the after show but there is a
fight that is just so wonderfully
ridiculous that I cannot wait to discuss
it with you guys it involves a color
let's see Mikaela also said yes I am
loving the Heather Chandler look thank
you so much
I'm dying in it right now cuz it's
really hot with the lights but it's like
sweaty but make it fashion Anika Lee
says oh my gosh the Heather Chandler
HBIC look is slang thank you guys
feeling sane Ryan hence Allah said I'm
really looking forward to hearing
Vanessa sing a solo and then I hope
Shoni gets back together cuz I can't
stand them fighting with each other
I completely agree as you guys have seen
me say I think that the Shoni breakup
was really random and I was really
confused last week we will be getting
some clarity this week and and some
uncovering some deep-rooted issues which
I was very excited about and it makes
things click a bit more still is
confusing though
okay let's see Arwa hisses to all the
parents in the show oh I lost it so so
sorry
I've got so many are well it's it's all
the parents in the show and at Shoney's
break and not seeing the farm so far I
hope that's something that happens about
Kevin in the farm and - a fun musical
episode
Evelynn ever never is very present in
this night's episode and the she
introduces some things from the farm
that are so bizarre and so weird that
I'm so excited for you guys to see it
she does some things that are truly
shocking because you think if it was
just kind of the squeaky clean girl
so we'll see what kind of big fun she
conjures up tonight
lots of hisses out there to Gladys I
still really enjoy her because I think
that it's nice to have a new Big Bad
entering the town and she's doing some
awful things don't get me wrong however
she's not Hiram so I'm here for it
peachy aesthetic said hisses to Jughead
actually for not telling FP about Gladys
all in good time I'm sure I think he's
just I think he just doesn't want to
compromise the fact that his parents are
together they're having a good time
there he's finally getting that family
dynamic and also his dad has just now
become the new sheriff so I think he's
just trying to see if he can fix the
problem by himself which once again
we've got all these teens who thinks
that they can hand all these adult
problems which is great and nice and
empowering but there's a really great
song tonight I don't know if it's
actually called 17 but it comes at a
perfect moment and it's about like why
don't we just be teenagers for a minute
let's see elegant blogs by Maddie how
regal said glad police say Gladys
doesn't sing no offense I just don't
like her character
Gladys does not sing tonight she sang
that one time in lobon doing and I think
that's hopefully all we're gonna get Amy
honestly they better Rock Heather's as I
love the musical and will legit cry if
they ruin it but also buzzing for Cheryl
and candy store her attitude will make
it amazing you guys candy store is a
song that comes up in this week's
episode it's my favorite song of the
episode the choreography is amazing what
happens is amazing and just I am so here
for it I think you're gonna love it
Sturken said I faked sick to watch this
that's very nice I hope you're feeling
better
Savannah what do you think the Shoni
shippers are gonna think about this
episode Savannah the Shawnee shippers
are gonna have a lot to say about this
episode and then I think you should come
back to the after show and tell me all
of your hisses and kisses because there
are some big moments that almost happen
there are some big revelations there are
some big showdowns a lot happens the one
thing that I will say is that Vanessa
Morgan looks amazing in this episode and
in one scene in particular
Abbie will you ever do an interview with
Trinity for those who don't know Trinity
plays the lovely jelly bean and goodness
gracious
I would love to interview Trinity she
hasn't been on set every time that we've
been up there so I haven't had the
opportunity yet but I think she's great
she's in tonight's episode she doesn't
really do much but there's one point
when she's just like popping gum and I'm
like go JV she's a mood as the kids say
as my friend Adam says it's a movement
okay Bella Rooney do we finally get
affectionate bug-head it's been too long
stay tuned quick but it's great dream
bunny 99 the fashions on Cheryl Veronica
and Betty aren't so amazing I'm old
enough to have seen Heather's when it
was new and I'm excited to see
Riverdale's take on it yes okay so this
is very much not so much Heather's
taking this is very much Riverdale not
taking on Heather's the movie but taking
on Heather's the musical so it's kind of
an adaptation of an adaptation if that
makes sense so the heart of it is all
still there it's just surprisingly a
more light version considering Riverdale
and Heather's are typically both really
dark subjects so it's really interesting
let's see Sara s your lipstick is fab
Thank You Sara
I appreciate that lover 21 I'm actually
excited to see more from Evelyn there
are many points when I cannot stand her
bear but I think that she's just very
adorable and seems to be happy to be
part of something with everyone you guys
know that I've said this every time I
think first of all I think Zoe - Graham
Mason who plays her is phenomenal every
time Hank and I watched the episode
together which we watch it together
each week my editor and I we have such a
fun time together every time we see a
scene between Lily or between Betty and
Evelyn we just like hit each other
because it's just so good they both just
elevate each other's actresses I loved
Evelyn little buggy intense eyes and in
tonight's episode she gets on your
nerves but I'd rather her get on your
nerves and hiram I'm so sorry you know I
love Mark Consuelos but I can't anymore
lacy aah I'm so sorry if I said your
name wrong here but lace yeah will there
be any barchi scenes like in the last
musical I love you so much
so there is a brief barchi exchange of
words does that help
it's not gonna be like with last year's
musical where they were playing two
characters in love and had all these
like super sweet like things together
it's not gonna be like that Cindy dude
why do you or what do you think it's
gonna happen between our Chi Josie with
Sweet Pea being a JD I will say that
Sweet Pea is not too keen to be playing
JD as Josie's on-screen or on stage love
interest he'd rather still be her
offstage love interest
Josie's a little bit taken right now or
so Archie wants her to be drama bring in
what song is Vanessa seen as Betty Finn
is not a character in the musical but
rather in the movie the NASA sings a
song and I don't know what it's called
but something that happens in it
so as I'm watching it I was like no
that's not what they're gonna do oh my
god that's what they're doing
Wow okay and I know that's vague and you
know it doesn't make any sense but once
you watch the episode and if Yuri watch
this it'll make sense
it's insane but like good but weird um
let's see mmm we have just a couple more
guys okay amber w28 says his sister
Shoni so tired of this whoa-oh-oh so
tired of this woe is me rich girl BS
Cheryl has going on what if Toni only
started stealing cuz Cheryl let her to
do it and got her kicked out of the
serpent's so amber we're not going to go
way way
back to when they got kicked out of the
serpents because we've talked about that
so much at this point and we all agree
that the whole stealing story line was
really weird and out of character and
just I'm not here for it but yes I will
agree that the the back and forth of
Shoni I guess is to build up their
relationship I guess because he can't be
happy all the time
looks like bug head this season like
they've been solid this whole time but
are we really loving it yeah but like no
it's just kind of in the same I don't
know I don't know okay Travis what's
your favorite Heather's quote slash
moment so many some of them I can't say
cuz they're not appropriate for the
internet right now I love a classic
what's your damage Heather or how very
or greetings and salutations you'll see
a lot of interpretations of these lines
but yes I there's a lot more I'm just
not gonna say it because I'm can't say
something nice don't say anything at all
okay
let's ease sort of they want to know
does anyone died in this episode you
guys I can't tell you that tell you that
watch it I don't know but once again I
will say there is a big show-stopping
moment once the musical is done much
like last year that helped you kind of I
don't know miss friends forever said I
want glass to say she's a better villain
than hiram and I can take her serious as
a villain as opposed to hiram fair and
good points and yes applause to that I
enjoyed Gladys I think she's really
dynamic I believe her cuz you can tell
that she's been through some stuff
shouldn't and she kind of grew up on the
wrong side of the tracks
but yeah I enjoyed Gladys I think she's
great
well I eventually get sick of her if
they keep putting her in all the
episodes and she takes over I don't know
maybe but for right now my disdain for
high room is just so prevalent that I'm
just willing to take any other person to
be the big bad that's why I've been like
take me to
farm I want the farm I want to see the
cows I want to see the Sheep I want to
see all the stuff Angelina are they
singing beautiful yes beautiful and they
sing it quite a bit throughout the
episode it's kind of like the through
line it's really nice little dark ghost
is dead girl walking going to be there
who's dead girl walking you tell me
maila says any clue on Reggie and Ronnie
Veronica is definitely gonna be going
through a lot of things in this episode
I'm not going to comment but I'm sure
you've seen in the promo but there's
some stuff going down in the lodge
household and it kind of throws Veronica
for a loop and along with a lot of other
things so we're gonna be seeing a lot of
interactions between Veronica and Reggie
as they're trying to figure out what
they are what they mean to each other
but I will say and this will be really
fun
so in our Sweetwater after-show I'm
going to be bringing you guys so many
interviews with the cast and during
seven seconds in heaven I will be
bringing new interviews from cami
Charles Cole and Lily and they're
actually weighing in on not only their
couples on-screen but also all the
couples so it'll be really interesting
and I can't wait for you guys to see
what they told us cuz someone says
something and my jaw dropped I couldn't
believe that this person said this to
our cameras and I think we're gonna
leave it right there
yeah now thank you all so much for
watching our live Sweetwater preview and
be sure to come back after you've
watched episode 316 chapter 51 big fun
because like I said I'm going to be
spoiling you with the most Riverdale
cast interviews we've ever put into one
episode but first hit the comments to
tell me if you can crack my three clues
what are you most excited to see in this
year's musical episode which couple do
you think needs to get back together
first give this video like hit subscribe
all those great things share your
thoughts with me and I'll see you after
the episode river babes bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]